nuestra pregunta en esta ocasión es qué
ecuación describe el crecimiento del
patrón de esta secuencia de bloques y
bueno para sacar el patrón de esta
secuencia de bloques que es lo que
queremos lo que queremos saber cuántos
lo que es va a haber en cualquiera de
los tiempos por ejemplo si nosotros
pensamos que es lo que va a pasar en el
tiempo 10 o cuando x vale 10 o cuando
nuestro número de términos vale 10
cuantos bloques vamos a tener y bueno
para esto lo que se me ocurre hacer
primero es una pequeña tablita acerca de
los términos y de la cantidad de bloques
que tenemos para ver qué es lo que está
pasando entonces aquí voy a poner el
número de términos y del lado derecho la
cantidad de bloques ahora fijémonos en
el primer término es decir cuando
teníamos el tiempo 1 teníamos un bloque
después en el segundo tiempo en el
segundo término agregamos una fila de
cuatro bloques por lo tanto es casi
igual al primer tiempo solamente que le
agregamos cuatro bloques y por lo tanto
nos dan cinco cuando nosotros tenemos el
tercer término pasa exactamente lo mismo
es casi lo mismo que el término 2
solamente que le aumentamos una fila de
cuatro bloques por lo tanto tenemos
cinco más cuatro bloques me van a dar
nueve bloques en el término 3 me dan 9
bloques y qué es lo que pasa en el
término 4 en el término 4 es exactamente
lo mismo que teníamos en el término 3
solamente que le agregamos otra fíjense
bien le agregamos otra columna de 4
bloques es lo mismo lo que pinta de
amarillo más otra columna de 4 bloques
por lo tanto tenemos 13 bloques ahora lo
que me encantaría saber es la ecuación
que rige este comportamiento es decir si
nosotros vemos los bloques o si nosotros
vemos estos numeritos cómo saber cuántos
lo que vamos a tener cuando x valga no
sé vamos a llamar a estos x para que nos
confundamos cuando x valga el número que
nosotros queramos fíjate bien cuando x
valía 1 teníamos 1 que es la condición
inicial cuando x valía todos tenemos una
hilera o una columna de 4 bloques cuando
x vale 3 tenemos dos hileras de cuatro
bloques es más aquí cuando x vale 1
podemos decir que tenemos 0 hileras o 0
columnas de 4
cuando x vale 2 tenemos una cuando x
vale 3 tenemos dos y cuando x vale 4
tenemos 3 columnas más de 4 bloques por
lo tanto lo que queremos saber es
cuántas columnas de cuatro bloques vamos
a agregar para x igual a lo que sea y
date cuenta de algo muy importante por
aquí va la idea la idea es agregar
columnas de cuatro bloques así que
déjenme escribirlo de esta manera para
que vayamos entendiendo este problema de
una forma mucho más matemática aquí voy
a poner la cantidad o el número de
bloques que yo tengo y entonces cómo
podemos encontrar la ecuación que me
describa la cantidad de bloques bueno si
te das cuenta todos empiezan con 1 aquí
tengo un bloque un bloque un bloque y un
bloque por lo tanto es uno más y algo le
tenemos que agregar y como estuvimos
analizando tiene que ver con la cantidad
de columnas de cuatro bloques que
agregamos pero si te das cuenta cuando x
vale uno tenemos cero cuando equivale
dos tenemos uno cuando x vale tres
tenemos dos y cuando x vale cuatro
tenemos tres esto en matemática se
escribe como x menos 1 x 1
la cantidad de columnas que vamos a
tener que ir agregando en cada uno de
los pasos por ejemplo aquí cuando x vale
2 tenemos una columna por lo tanto es x
menos 1 cuando que vale 3 tenemos dos
columnas por lo tanto es x menos 1
cuando x vale 4 tenemos tres columnas
solamente por lo tanto es x menos 1 y
bueno 1 2 3 1 2 1 y en un principio
teníamos 0 columnas pero cada una de
estas columnas tiene 4 bloques por lo
tanto esta es la cantidad de columnas el
número de columnas lo voy a escribir
aquí y cada una de estas columnas hay
que multiplicarla por la cantidad de
bloques que en este caso eran 4 entonces
tenemos x menos uno por cuatro cuatro
bloques cuatro bloques cuatro bloques
por todos lados por lo tanto esta es la
ecuación que describe la cantidad de
bloques que vamos a tener en una cierta
x dada y vamos a intentar simplificar un
poco esto lo que se me ocurre es
multiplicar y distribuir el 44 por x es
4x y 4 x menos 1 me va a dar menos 4
entonces me queda 1 más 4 x menos 4
1 x 4 es menos 4 entonces me queda 14 x
4 y esto lo podemos reducir todavía un
poco más el número de bloques como lo
calculamos vamos a reducirlo entonces me
quedan 14 x menos 41 y el menos 4 se
reducen y me queda menos 3 por lo tanto
esto es igual a 4 x menos 3 y ya está
con eso tenemos una ecuación mucho más
sencilla para calcular la cantidad de
bloques que podemos tener en una x dada
por ejemplos x vale 50 tendríamos 4 x 50
que son 200 200 menos 3 tendríamos 197
bloques en el paso se encuentra
tendríamos 197 bloques y esta general
porque ya tenemos nuestra fórmula bueno
a partir de ahorita quiero ver un método
alternativo para resolver este mismo
problema porque el crecimiento de este
patrón es un crecimiento lineal a estas
sucesiones se les conoce como sucesiones
aritméticas y bueno qué otra forma
podemos pensar para resolver este
problema lo que se me ocurre es que como
el crecimiento es lineal
pensemos en cuánto vale la pendiente
la pendiente es un concepto que vamos a
utilizar y la pendiente la sacábamos
como la cantidad de bloques en este caso
la cantidad de bloques que nosotros
cambiamos de uno a otro entre la
cantidad de x que vamos a cambiar de un
valor a otro qué quiere decir esto
si nosotros calculamos la pendiente
entonces vamos a ver cuánto cambian los
bloques a comparación de cuánto es lo
que está cambiando la equis esa es la
definición de pendiente por lo tanto
vamos a hacerlo a ver la cantidad de
bloques como cambian delta de los
bloques es decir la diferencia que hay
entre cinco menos uno entonces vamos a
dividir abajo me queda dos menos uno
estoy comparando el tiempo 2 con el
tiempo 1 y arriba me va a quedar como
cambian los bloques 5 menos 1 y por lo
tanto vamos a ver 5 menos 1 pues esto es
muy sencillo es 42 menos unos 1 y 4
entre 1 es 4 es decir que la pendiente
de esta recta o de este cambio lineal es
4 y esto ya lo sospechábamos porque cada
vez que nosotros aumentamos en
un valor de x nosotros lo que aumenta
vamos era una columna de cuatro bloques
porque la forma alternativa de resolver
este problema es la siguiente yo voy a
decir que el número de bloques va a
estar dada por una ecuación de una recta
porque tiene un comportamiento lineal y
una recta se ve como la pendiente que
multiplica x es decir 4 que multiplica a
x al tiempo dado o al termino dado más
una constante mx + ver 4 x + b es la
ecuación de una recta tenemos que la
pendiente vale 4 ahora lo que habrá que
investigar es cuánto vale ven para sacar
a b lo único que hay que hacer es
agarrar un punto o dicho de otra manera
agarrar una equis y una cantidad de
bloques por ejemplo en este caso x va a
valer 1 b no sabemos cuánto vale y la
cantidad de bloques va a valer también 1
porque lo que nosotros ya sabemos es que
en el término 1 la cantidad de bloques
es 1 1 es igual a 4 más ven y si
despejamos de que me queda que menos 4 y
menos 4 de los dos lados uno menos 4 me
va a dar menos
y 4 menos 4 se cancelan entonces de este
lado solamente me queda la vez y ya la
tengo b vale menos 3 ya con eso calculé
cuánto vale 20 b vale menos 3 y ya con
esto tengo la ecuación de una recta mx
más ven y espero que esto no te haya
confundido mucho porque si te confundió
puedes utilizar lo que vimos en un
principio pero lo que yo te quiero
contar es lo siguiente la pendiente la
sacamos viendo cuánto cambiaban los
bloques de una equis a otra es decir
calculamos la pendiente viendo cómo
cambiaban los bloques según lo que
cambiaba la equis y la vez la b la
sacamos utilizando cualquier punto o
cualquiera de los valores que tenemos en
esta tabla usamos 11 pero podemos haber
utilizado cualquiera que se nos había
ocurrido 25 3 y 9 lo que sea pero bueno
espero que si te haya servido toda esta
información y además me gustaría mucho
que todo esto te hubiera resultado
divertido